what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have two
special guests on my channel my dad and
my cousin aiden so you won't believe
what's going on today i was invited to
go do a video with fredo bang and
because like loki he's been to jail for
attempted murder i think my dad's going
with me
yay
are you excited to go i'm so excited
does your mom do you think she's gonna
kill you after this oh
run out the door absolutely a little
youtuber is tough i'm really tired of
being broke dad a quarter mile i can't
mooch off of you forever
that's why we're going ready
we're going in this like nice gated
community in this wow
giant van
like
which makes it ski masks at this point
i don't film when i meet somebody
because it's just kind of awkward like
meeting someone for the first time and
putting a camera in their face but it
was a really funny scene i pulled up to
fredo banks house in this nice gated
community in this beat up van with my
dad and my cousin anyways this is the
reaction video that we filmed that day
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have two
special guests on the channel my cousin
aiden and little man be me i won't
recognize my videos
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos today we are
reacting to don't miss what is this song
about basically
when people get you as far as like
enemies and
anybody against you just tell them don't
miss you know what i'm saying because
you gotta you know always come back
harder i think like don't mess whatever
whatever
evil thing they trying to do to me don't
miss because i'm always coming hard oh
so you're saying if you're gonna get me
like get me because i'm going to come
back and i'll be stronger
hey joel always shooting outside
[Music]
every day
[Music]
[Music]
always
hold us there putting stuff false
stories out for me
all right what'd they say that was false
oh there's a bunch of them
i like the opening like
like the video of it but it's very it's
like it's real it's not like
like i don't want to bring so much other
people into it but like some people just
get caught but this is like real no i
think you you tell them i like the
difference between production you know
yeah yeah yeah i don't really like
production videos i try to keep it as
natural as possible
are those were those all the letters you
got and you got out of jail yeah
how many did you have
i feel like i had to throw 100 away when
i was getting shipped because they won't
let me travel with it
[Music]
and if you know it like i know
[Music]
i think i really like videos that tell a
full story so i really like like when i
see a music video that is like a really
good story in italy
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry sometimes in rap videos they
talk so fast i can't hear it i said i
don't want a wife i said [ __ ] love and
put my drink
on a pedestal
what's a drink out
oh it's a fire
i wish i did not have all here
[Laughter]
so so that goes on the pedestal over
love and none of the um you can't
deceive you you can't deceive you you
won't deceive love won't deceive you
oh but your gun won't that you don't
care carry your hump right yeah but what
was the first thing that you bought when
you got out though
uh
first day
like uh it was my phone yeah i drove
straight from the gym to the phone store
with like five guys i ain't with the
rider i come with a meds like lady gaga
one defenders whip this rocket
[Music]
if
[Music]
so was that the first meal you had after
you got out yeah and was it like a big
party like we're a lot of people no
like ten of us okay if you ever take a
shot at a [ __ ] like me then you're a
bit nice
[Music]
if you ever take a shot
[Music]
[Music]
what'd you say about smoking you don't
smoke like i smoke
what are they saying if you smoke like i
smoked i was basically on a reference to
the original song because this song was
snapping up i said it's not a sample
regulators basically that's the sample
right now so i was referencing a song if
you smoke like i smoked and get high
like every day i say you smoke like i
smoke and your ops don't always be
pissed oh wait i learned
okay i know this one he would say and op
is like the opposition and that's like
the opposing
game right or opponent opponent i
thought it was like the opposing like no
not gang i don't know okay okay so it's
just like your opponent
it's like it's like someone against you
oh it doesn't have to be like once
you're just like um
if you go if you look on wrestling it's
gonna to say
i liked that one
would you what would you rank it out of
five actually out of five i'd say out of
ten i'd give it like no i do five skills
it has to be wonderful i'll tell you why
no no one to ten people are too nice on
one to ten so three is like out average
if you look at me i don't think the same
no it's not nope
like i've listened to a lot of your
music right so i'd say out of
most your songs i would say that's like
four four point five
i like that one more because it's like
it's like something you can listen to no
matter what yeah because i'll be tired
of dropping gangsta song but i'll be
happy to give it to the core family like
the fan base that ben from from the
start that's what they beat one here
obviously
since i write i'd rather drop the
gangster songs and dean when i drop my
project i have more
good music i actually i think that
before because i think it was i really
like videos that tell a story it's like
a cool story
i appreciate that would you say you're
more critical of your music or less
critical
how long did it take you to like film
and do everything
but i don't i don't like doing long
video shoots
i don't believe in taking 14 hours to do
two minutes are video shoots like fun
typically like i know that was a more
serious one but like when everyone's out
i was cool but now i don't they don't do
fun for me
you were doing a youtube video y'all
behind the camera and i was like smile
throw your hair back
you know what i'm saying
speak a little louder if i just keep
telling you
yes
okay guys um let me know in the comments
what you read this song um one to five
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell